bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord combien
d'opposants sont toujours en détention
dans quelles conditions est ce que vous
avez pu parler à pascal affi n'guessan
qu'elle l'un des leaders de l'opposition
le président du hesse pays d'illégal je
rappelle que nous sommes un collectif et
à l'intérieur de ce collectif
il ya différents on sait qu'ils sont
constitués où chacun des lutteurs
l'opposition et des responsables de la
société civile relativement à la
situation de monsieur pascal affi
n'guessan il a des conseils également
qu'ils sont membres du collectif
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas vous donner
exactement le nombre de personnes qui
sont à leur accueil dans les liens de la
détention qui sont en même temps leader
de l'opposition est responsable de la
justice civile
mais ce que je pourrais vous dire est
que relativement par exemple monsieur
affi n'guessan il n'a pas encore pu être
en contact avec ses conseils il y a des
difficultés à ce niveau en profitons de
voir que de votre antenne pourquoi
dénoncer
il est important pour le mis en cause
puisque il est fait l'objet d'une
procédure en instruction il est
important que le mis en cause puisse
avoir la possibilité testud elle elle
prévue
avocat au jour d'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas et nous pensons que les
mesures doivent être prises afin que ce
dernier l'a son contact avec les avocats
pour que cet effort soit h et dans un
rapport amnesty international parle
d'une dizaine de membres de l'opposition
arrêtés
par ailleurs on évoque une détention
secrète de pascal affi n'guessan
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait nous dire à ce
niveau et ce qu'on pouvait confirmer
justement comme je vous ai dit tout les
avocats ne sont même pas en mesure de
pouvoir en contact ou est en contact
avec le client a fortiori savoir où il
se trouve
à l'heure actuelle que je profite de
l'occasion pour dénoncer cette somme qui
a été imposée pas dit le procureur qui
aurait demandé aux avocats de l'ue
produit une demande que les avocats
fasse une demande pour être autorisé à
est en contact avec le client
moi je suis très surpris une telle
demande le procureur est une partie dans
la procédure actuelle qui oppose
monsieur affi n'guessan a au procureur
de la république est généralement 10 mai
chafic et son pote ministère public et
la procédure pendante devant un juge
d'instruction qui a été saisi par le
fait que la république il n'appartient
donc pas à monsieur pourquoi la
république d'un précieux qui est le
contradicteur de monsieur affi n'guessan
et ne lui appartient pas à lui
d'apprécier de l'opportunité de
permettre à monsieur affi n'guessan de
rentrer en contact avec les avocats ou
pas et en plus madame de 12 est
important que le lieu de détention que
ce soit monsieur affi n'guessan parce
qu'il faudrait pas qu on personnalise
également le départ c'est une question
de respect de la loi que ce soit
monsieur affi n'guessan que ce soit
n'importe qui qui fait l'objet d'une
procédure
ce dernier doit pouvoir être en contact
avec ses conseils
elles sont le détention de reçus de là
dessus m là bien sûr de pas mettre ça
qui quels sont les chefs d'accusations
portées à l'encontre des opposants des
cadres de l'opposition qui ont eu
d'arrêt
on nous parle de sédition globalement
particulière tous sont poursuivis pour
les mêmes faits convocation à une
insurrection participation à un
mouvement insurrectionnel
il ya même une question de ce terroriste
qui est invoquée or voilà un peu les
différents chefs d'accusation qui sont
reprochés à la fin de mon des leaders de
l'opposition et de la société civile
parmi ces leaders de l'opposition ont
incité donc pascal affi n'guessan qui
avait lancé le gouvernement de
transition civile avec henri konan-bédié
ce dernier lui n'a pas été arrêtée
comment vous l'expliquez on sait qu'il a
commencé à discuter avec le président
élu alassane ouattara
pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a pas été arrêté
écoutez moi tant qu'avocat moral je
pense qu'à son de la loi dont on se
demande déjà à se conformer à la loi
respecte relativement à mon appréciation
mois vous pourrez vous donné par les
casseurs tu la question je rappelle que
njawe était un autre à notre état est
prévue par le code de procédure pénale
qui est chargé des routes
cette autorité qui est chargé de
possibles mais rien de tout le temps je
pense qu'il serait intéressant que vous
conservez certainement cette question à
monsieur le procureur vous demandez
pourquoi est ce que il ya un tri
pourquoi c'était important de
l'opposition font l'objet d'une
procédure à leur encontre sont
interpellés pendant que d'autres ne le
sont pas je pense que le poids répondre
pour terminer encore ce rapport
d'amnesty international qui demande donc
aux autorités d'enquêter sur les
violences post électorales il ya quand
même une guerre des chiffres puisque les
autorités parlent d'une dizaine de morts
comité justement des droits de l'homme
nationales des droits de l'homme parle
de 55 morts et 2 282 blessés il ya
encore des violences dans le centre du
pays
quelle est votre appréciation par
rapport à la situation
moi mon mauvais sens qu'il est clair
vous savez nous vivons dans un état dans
lequel dans lequel yade eric et non tout
ce que nous demandons jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est le respect de la loi
c'est le respect des tests que nous
avons décidé de nous et d'éditer et
d'appliquer ces règles vous parle
également des chiffres qui sont donnés
tantôt pas le par le gouvernement le
cirque y sont donnés tantôt par hertz au
sein de l'opposition mais très
intéressante pour attraper des débats ce
qu'une enquête impartiale et
indépendante soit minutes à l'effet de
pouvoir déterminer clairement le soutien
d'abord les responsabilités et enfin
connaît c'est le nommé gza deux victimes
relativement à cette situation
moi je veux dire je vais également
ajouté que nous avons décidé de nous
imposer des règles
nous sommes dans une société et la
société dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
ne pas avoir son équilibre que par le
respect de la loi
nous ne voulons même pas rentrer dans
les débats du fond du savoir si les
faits qui sont imputés à l'arrêt qui
sont un achat judicieux à la chasse des
différents des différents leaders de
l'opposition sont avérées ou pas nous ne
rentrons pas dans cet état mais nous
demandons que le respect des règles de
forme notamment la possibilité que la
loi offre à tous ceux qui sont mis en
cause de pouvoir être assisté d'un
conseil de pouvoir visiter à leurs
conseils et les membres de leur famille
le cercle est établie soit respecté mais
profite également de l'occasion ativan
maintenant être 5,8 à son existence de
l'opposition parce qu'ils bénéficient
des droits de parapets l'immunité
parlementaire
mais on pouvait produire le procureur a
opté pour l'ouverture d'une information
chip au parc hassène information
judiciaire est ouverte
on doit impérativement obtenir la levée
de le gougaud avant de pouvoir
poursuivre ces personnes là merci merci
merci à vous mettre à innocent sec et je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat à la cour
membre du collectif des avocats des
leaders de l'opposition en côte d'ivoire